come on we gotta get out we gotta go I
don't care who's in there let's get him
out
no no no no no no come on out out
my 92 year old okay that's fine happy
where's he at we're getting out back no
no not out back not out back not out
back not out there where you want us to
go baby we gotta go up front
[Music]
this entire side of the house is on fire
no all right all right that's fine
no come on do we have a wheelchair or
anything
all right sir hey you carry him come
here grab a place
it's fine grab his legs grab his legs
I don't care where we go
ma'am you need to get out of the house
about get downstairs here
somebody move the fence
we're good again if the dogs run they
run
no all right let's get him somebody get
a share let's get him all the way down
to the road
I know body I know
but I gotta get you safe
I know it hurts
stay with us
everybody out of the house
let's put him in the yard
let's go let's go we're gonna go all the
way
whatever happened
please leave this down straight on the
ground I know
I know be good thank you honey you ain't
gonna make it to 97.
it's still in that house thank you I
know that's wrong it's like 200 dispatch
201 dispatch
hey I got him out of the house
everybody's out
okay
still here grandpa I know
come on get a little bit over gotta get
over all right
let's get him over there oh yeah is
there anybody else
[Music]
I'm telling you
puppies are out okay come on
if that propane tank explodes I guess
that's why
go
I'll be honest oh you honey I'm trying
to tell her about possessions
I mean it sucks for the dogs but you'll
get them
let's go
305 303 channel two
let's go get out of the house
did she go back in the house
I got one that just went back in the
house for a dog all right she's coming
out now let's go come on
again
I don't care about them I know you do I
care about you
come on we gotta go across the street
what am I gonna do leave them in the
yard yeah sure I'll set the gate then
get back let's go
check the Pig please I'll come out
okay we're gonna go
away stay I'm afraid
okay okay
yes everybody is out
so freaking long come on I
am
yeah
I'm good buddy good you're good we got
grandpa fuck everybody's out yeah and
then she went fucking back in for the
stupid talk that's so mad there will be
more
or anything
they had him let's go and they're like
you can't walk
I said I'm going to take his arms get
off his legs
there's a very large
barriers
um
I mean maybe these people
[Applause]
okay
here okay
out of Florida
Nora Queen and an ocean six victory Nora
[Music]
so what's the issue just checking to
make sure
all right well
get out of here
on the inside Karen
I don't see myself
[Music]
again
I don't know it sounds like they're
inside right
here
listen listen Okay when I got here they
were all still in the house
and I'm like
we gotta go
and then she refused to get out
yeah
and I was like we gotta go and they said
Dad can't walk so me I don't know where
the other guy is there was another guy
look at that